ja liebe hörerinnen und hörer ich
begrüße sie sehr herzlich zufolge
181 des einspruchs podcast heute am 17
oktober 20 21 mein name ist helene
bobrowski ich moderiere den podcast
einmal im monat und an meiner seite ist
wie jede woche pia lorenz hallo mein ich
bin rechtsanwältin und journalistin
hallo von mir auch ein herzliches
willkommen an diesem etwas gräulichen
oktobertag haben wir einiges in petto
für unsere lieben hörerinnen und hörer
im wir beginnen mit einer kurzen haus
mitteilung und das ist mal was schönes
nämlich eine einladung an alle studenten
und young professionals also junge
anwältinnen und anwälte oder andere jura
interessierte zur jurack on und zwar das
ist die jura jobmesse wo man noch mal an
seiner juristischen karriere feilen kann
wo man sich anschauen kann was es
eigentlich alles gibt wo man als jurist
überall enden kann zum beispiel auch
beim einspruch podcast wie hier zwei
die frage was man vom leben
[Musik]
man kann ja das ist ja das schöne am
jura studium mannheim ja alles damit
machen genau man kann viel damit machen
und die nicht juristen halten einen
immer für wahnsinnig klug das hat auch
einen grossen vorteil weil man den
unterschied zwischen besitz und eigentum
zb und erklären kann dem unterschiedlich
so also die seelower konnten zudem
herzlich eingeladen wird auch von
unserer seite findet statt am 2 11 in
frankfurt und am 8 12 in
münchen bei der bmw in münchen
live findet statt in der tat anders als
im vergangenen jahr wo es nur online war
kann man nun tatsächlich mit
arbeitgebern kanzleien unternehmen usw
sprechen
die erklären einem was für
jobmöglichkeiten es in ihren jeweiligen
kann sein unternehmen gibt usw usw
wie gesagt also zweiter november in
frankfurt cup europa und am 8 dezember
bmw welt in münchen
herzliche einladung und natürlich gibt
es alle weiteren informationen zur
anmeldung unter www jurack on.de jura
geschrieben jura und dann cn das ist
wahrscheinlich bekannt so und jetzt
gehts zum heutigen programm worum geht's
heute wir sprechen in der rubrik was war
über den sogenannten bds über das bds
urteil des berliner verwaltungsgerichts
aus der schon vor ein paar tagen
außerdem über daraus was eigentlich aus
der stvo novelle und ihrer illustren
geschichte geworden ist unser
schwerpunktthema heute ist polen und die
entscheidung vom vergangenen donnerstag
die ja viel kritik hervorgerufen hat und
europa tatsächlich in einer ganz
entscheidenden frage in den grundfesten
erschüttert hat dazu haben wir einen
experten eingeladen reinhard feser aus
frankfurt der das mit uns im einzelnen
diskutieren wird
dann haben wir noch unter der rubrik was
kommt das whistleblowing gesetzt dass
nun ja umgesetzt werden oder dass nun in
kraft treten muss und wir haben
natürlich wie immer ein gerechtes urteil
dass uns pia vorstellt so wir fangen
aber an
mit dem thema bds was spd es für die die
es nicht wissen eine abkürzung für die
worte boykott bei westwind sessions und
das ist eine bewegung die ihren ursprung
in palästina hat und die eben zur zum
boykott von
bestimmten produkten aus aufruft und
gemeinhin als antisemitisch gilt so
jedenfalls hat es auch der bundestag
beschlossen 2009 10 gab es einem ja eine
meinungsäußerung sage ich jetzt einfach
mal neutral
über diesen wds und wurde eben gesagt
die bewegung sei antisemitisch und
organisationen die mit dem bds
sympathisieren oder mit ihr sonst wie
zusammenarbeiten dürfen auch von mit
deutschem geld nicht mehr gefördert
werden
genau weil nämlich der hintergrund ist
das bds das existenzrecht israels
infrage stellt und dass wir mit der
deutschen staatsräson schlichtweg
unvereinbar ist an diesem beschluss gab
es politisch einige kritik das hat
durchaus zum beispiel bei den grünen der
fraktion für heftige
auseinandersetzungen geführt weil leute
die sich in dem in israel konflikt gut
auskennen eben sagen na ja in
deutschland
weiterhin
entwicklungshilfe zusammenarbeit zb
palästina leisten will ist diese
einschränkung dass es überhaupt keine
finanzielle förderung mehr geben darf
sobald jemand mit der bewegung
sympathisiert das würde sei vollkommen
kontraproduktiv weil im grunde genommen
in palästina ist schwer ist jemanden zu
finden der nicht irgendwelche kontakte
kontakte zur pds bewegung hat dies eben
sehr weit verbreitet und ist so sagen
jedenfalls kenner auch nicht
ganz wie ein monolithischer block
sondern da gibt es eben auch unter
sozusagen schattierungen und
unterschiede das spiegelt sich so im
beschluss des bundestages nicht wider
sondern die eben ganz generell die bds
bewegung als antisemitisch
klassifizieren ich will da jetzt
überhaupt keine stellung nehme ich gebe
nur wieder das ist schon an diesem
beschluss damals einige
auseinandersetzung gab es gab etliche
abgeordnete die eine art protokoll
erklärung abgegeben hatten also sich von
bestimmten dingen
distanziert haben oder ihre sonder
meinung dazu
kundgetan haben genau man muss
vielleicht auch noch mal einmal deutlich
sagen dass die bds bewegung sich selbst
natürlich keineswegs als antisemitisch
sehen möchte genau genau die eben wobei
also der begriff boykott ist natürlich
der da mitschwingt der
erregt natürlich sofort assoziationen
die antisemitisch sind aber die brauchen
eben nur darauf dass man
dass man wie gehört werden will als
stimme und die sich tatsächlich eben wie
du sagst hier nicht als antisemitisch
verstehen es kam wie es kommen musste
diese politischen auseinandersetzung
führten auch in rechtliche
auseinandersetzung und drei kläger also
drei menschen die sich als unterstützer
der bds bewegung bezeichnen klagten vor
dem berliner verwaltungsgericht weil sie
sich in ihren grundrechten auf
meinungsfreiheit versammlungsfreiheit
und dem allgemeinen persönlichkeitsrecht
verletzt sahen weil sie sich an diesem
begriff der pds bewegungs antisemitisch
genau das ist sozusagen der kern auf den
sie sich mit ihrer klage beziehen und
warum sind sie dann heimlich zum
verwaltungsgericht gegangen da ging es
doch schon mal los da ging es schon mal
los wie wir wissen aus unserem studium
ist ein verwaltungsgericht nur für
verwaltungsgerichtliche streitigkeiten
zuständig also solche die nicht
verfassungsrechtlich sind das war schon
mal die erste frage ist dafür nicht
vielleicht das verfassungsrecht gericht
zuständig da hat das berliner
verwaltungsgericht einen ganz
pragmatischen weg ist ist es gegangen
hat gesagt na ja irgendjemand muss halt
über diese frage entscheiden und hat
verwiesen auf ein urteil des
verfassungsgerichtshofs nordrhein
westfalen wo eben in einem ähnlich
gelagerten fall entschieden wurde dass
die anti das ein anti bds beschluss des
landtags in nordrhein-westfalen
eben gemeinde mit einer
verfassungsbeschwerde genau nicht mit
der verfassungsbeschwerde angegriffen
werden kann sondern eben vor dem
verwaltungsgericht angegriffen werden
müsse und hat man gesagt also man kann
jetzt nicht es können nicht sowohl
verfassungsgericht als auch
verwaltungsgerichts angesehen nicht
zuständig deswegen das war die
zuständigkeit gab aber noch andere
fragen im rahmen der zulässigkeit die
erörtert wurden also etwa die frage
können eigentlich menschen die in dem
beschluss gar nicht namentlich genannt
sind dagegen vorgehen hat nicht
vielleicht der gesetzgeber einfach nur
eine meinung kundgetan
es handelt sich ja gar nicht um ein
formales gesetzgebungsverfahren also was
ist eigentlich der angriff gegenstand
diese fragen hat die auch durchaus
schwierig sind habe das
verwaltungsgericht
mit einigen wie soll man sagen und
einiger großzügigkeit
behandelt so dass die klage jedenfalls
schon mal zulässig war sie wurde dann
aber als unbegründet abgewiesen mit
einer interessanten begründung würde ich
jetzt mal so wertfrei sagen nämlich
darin heißt es dass der beschluss des
bundestages eine positionsbestimmung des
deutschen bundestages einer kontroversen
debatte sei und damit habe der bundestag
sein allgemein politisches mandat
ausgeübt der beschluss so die richter
des verwaltungsgerichts greife aber
nicht in das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht der kläger ein das
treffe keine besuche
personenbezogenen sondern nur
sachbezogene aussagen so also die
begründung und
allerdings und das ist interessant ist
die berufung zum oberverwaltungsgericht
zugelassen worden so das ist sein kann
dass hier in dieser frage noch gar nicht
das letzte wort gesprochen wurde wer was
hältst du davon
also ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt
vollkommen und schließlich das was ich
davon halten soll ich glaube dass dafür
auch meine verfassungsrechtlichen
kenntnisse schlicht nicht ausreichen ein
dumpfes juristisches sagt mir dass ich
das merkwürdig finde dass dieser
bundestagsbeschluss tatsächlich
überhaupt keine keinen eingriff
darstellen soll also weil eigentlich
muss man ja schon faktisch sagen wenn
der deutsche bundestag sagt keine ahnung
ist sollte vielleicht niemand mehr dem
bds räume zur verfügung stellen dann hat
das natürlich irgendwie keine gesetzes
qualität aber es hat ja auch nicht gar
keine qualität die irgendwie einem
eingriff gleichkommen könnte und also
damit habe ich rechtlich schon ein
bisschen problem ich glaube schon dass
das eher was ist vorüber
verfassungsgericht entscheiden müssen
das ist die eine frage die andere frage
ist natürlich wirklich ist da jetzt der
kläger der mit der pds bewegung aus
welchen gründen auch immer sympathisiert
ist der in seinen rechten betroffen weil
die bds bewegung vom boden des tag mit
mehrheit der mitglieder als
antisemitisch eingestuft wird naja die
conti argumentieren ja aber schon mit so
nah ich sag mal mittelbaren
betroffenheit verliert zum beispiel
sagen wir kriegen jetzt in irgendwelchen
kommunen keine räume mehr für uns ist
das 4
geworden einfach eine versammlung zum
beispiel zu organisieren genau das
stimmt natürlich auch andererseits würde
ich auch argumentieren naja ist
verbietet ein in deutschland verbietet
einem in deutschland niemand dieser pds
bewegung damit sie sympathisieren dafür
einzutreten für die ziele aber man muss
möglicherweise eben dann auch mit den
konsequenzen leben
dies hat das die mehrheit im bundestag
der meinung ist
wer ein wer das existenzrecht israels
infrage stellt in deutschland ja dass
das bezeichnen wir als antisemitisch und
finden das nicht gut also ich frag mich
halt immer auf die meinungsfreiheit
bedeutet dass uns jetzt überspitzt zu
sagen was man nur applaus krieg sondern
meinungsfreiheit bedeutet ja auch man
kann seine meinung äußern und muss halt
damit leben dass andere
menschen oder eben in dem fall der
bundestag also
verfassungsorgane ja ein vorhaben als zb
antisemitisch oder ein anderer vom
verwerflich einstufen oder da bin ich
total bei dir das ist ja im moment auch
eine gern geführte diskussion also muss
ich dann irgendwie wenn ich von von
meiner meinung und von meinen freiheiten
gebrauch machen möchte dann die
konsequenzen tragen das stichwort imf
debatte usw da bin ich absolut seiner
meinung aber ich glaube da sind halt
auch formal und juristisch noch einige
hürden drin zum beispiel solche sachen
wie irgendwie ist es jetzt wirklich nur
ein werturteil des bundestags wenn der
bundestag sagt dass die
argumentationsmuster und methoden der
bds bewegung antisemitisch sind also
kann da der bundestag ein ein werturteil
abgeben ohne dass das irgendwelche
rechtlichen und damit ihr auch rechtlich
angreifbaren konsequenzen hat also da
hab ich glaube ich tatsächlich eher so
eine formaljuristische
schlechtes bauchgefühl als dass ich mir
in der sache schon eine finale meinung
gebildet hat ja also das können wir
vielleicht jetzt auch gar nicht gehen
ich will nur sagen was ist das problem
aber
ich würde sagen dass aus einem jahr
einer kampagne aus dem jahr 2005 da hat
die pds bewegung ihre ziele formuliert
und da steht drin israel müsse die
okkupation und kolonialisierung allen
arabischen landes beenden das grundrecht
seiner arabischen und palästinensischen
bürger auf volle gleichheit anerkennen
und das recht der palästinensischen
flüchtlinge auf eine rückkehr
in ihrer heimat und zu ihrem eigentum
gemäß der un-resolution schützen und
fördern
so und dann ist eben noch ergänzt wird
das durch dadurch dass führende
vertreter der bds bewegung aber wohl
nicht die bewegung als solche eben das
existenzrecht israels infrage stellt
also da gibt es auch jede menge
forschung zu dem thema wobei man sagen
muss dass forschung in diesem bereich
eben auch nicht im luftleeren raum
stattfindet sondern natürlich auch
politisch co notiert ist und
das ist natürlich ein echtes wie soll
man sagen pulverfass in dass wir hier
ein stechen ja auch und vor allem eben
in deutschland aus naheliegenden der
berechtigten gründen als erbe
rechtlichen gründen du sagst ja und wir
sehen eben auch das natürlich gerichte
mit diesen fragen am ende überfordert
sind ja also das ist ein ich habe sie
erzählt 1 1 durchaus kontroverser
prozess auch innerhalb des bundestages
gewesen wo man sich auch mit experten
und erhalten hat usw eine
meinungsbildung stattgefunden hat die
dann auch nach dem beschluss noch weiter
ging die auseinandersetzung darüber und
zu glauben dass jetzt ein
verwaltungsgericht bei allem respekt vor
dem verwaltungsgericht in berlin aber
das ist natürlich vollkommen überfordert
damit jetzt zu sagen was in dem fall
richtig und falsch ist zumal ist
wahrscheinlich ein echtes richtig und
falsch zur frage wie gehen wir mit
dieser also mit dem mit dieser bewegung
unter dem im bereich der
meinungsfreiheit um ja das ist ja
nochmal was also nicht nur wie gehen wir
mit dieser bewegung um sondern was
bedeutet dass sie beim beim
meinungsaustausch ist eben eine
komplizierte frage die glaube ich im
gesellschaftlichen dialog beantwortet
werden muss und nicht von einem gericht
insofern war es wahrscheinlich auch eine
ja vielleicht eine kluge entscheidung
ist so zu entscheiden als zu sagen ein
beschluss des bundestages greift in die
rechte ein wenn man sich überlegt was
das für ein fass aufgemacht hätte hätten
sie liegen
wäre die klage erfolgreich gewesen und
mag man sich eigentlich auch nicht
wirklich aus denken na ja gut aber dass
die geschichte weiter geht es glaube ich
auch klar und auch juristisch weiter
geht also wie gesagt
berufung ist zugelassen wegen
grundsätzlicher bedeutung und der anwalt
der bds bewegung ahmed am bett hat auch
schon angekündigt dass er zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und eventuell
auch zum egmr nach straßburg gehen
möchte genauso werden es weiter
verfolgen und kommt jetzt in etwas sage
ich mal
lebend gesehen haben um zu leben und an
unserer bewegung dran sind nämlich die
stvo novelle in ihrer einer weiteren
episode corinna wäre so glücklich wenn
sie heute da wäre weil das muss man
wissen die behörden und hörer oft sagt
corinna ein thema ich sage langweilig
und corinna sagt aber das ist doch so
lebensnah kommen wir machen das und
deswegen würde sie sich bestimmt sehr
freundlich bestimmt wird sie auch im
urlaub den podcast hören dass wir heute
über die bußgeld novelle sprechen die
letztes wochenende
letztes wochenende letzten freitag vom
bundesrat abgesegnet wurde der
bußgeldkatalog wurde vor allem verändert
und das ist natürlich absolut lebensnah
weil es bedeutet das jetzt
verkehrsverstöße höher sanktioniert
werden um das stand im vordergrund den
rad- und fußverkehr zu erhöhen ich
glaube das ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr
ein thema bei euch in berlin als jetzt
bei uns in köln liebe elena aber es ist
ja tatsächlich so dass es irgendwie
mittlerweile fast schon einen
straßenkampf gibt zwischen radfahrern
und fußgängern auf der einen seite und
autofahrern auf der anderen seite und
deswegen werden jetzt park und
halteverbote wesentlich stärker bußgeld
belegt bis zu 110 euro kann das jetzt
kosten wenn man auch mg oder radweg
parkt früher waren das maximal 35 euro
wenn lkw-fahrer das natürlich
tatsächlich eine wichtige regelung die
jetzt getroffen wurde die
schrittgeschwindigkeit missachten wenn
sie rechts abbiegen innerorts dann
kostet sie das einfach nur wenn gar
nichts passiert 70 euro wenn pkw fahrer
das tun und dabei fuß oder radfahrer
fußgänger oder radfahrer gefährden
können sie auch ein bußgeld zahlen
müssen und zwar von 140 euro plus
fahrverbot und es gibt jetzt ein
bußgeldtatbestand des sogenannten doris
ich mir war das noch gar nicht klar dass
es dafür ein wort gibt das ist das
phänomen wenn man als autofahrer
unvorsichtig die tür öffnet und dann
mann dazu zu kollisionen oder fast
kollision mit
radfahrern beiträgt das ist übrigens so
unglaublich gefährlich ist ihr grab
genommen genau und das ist jetzt
tatsächlich auch sanktioniert worden
wenn es da zu einer kollision oder fast
kollision kommt dann kann einen auch das
40 oder 50 euro kosten wenn das jetzt
irgendwie im verschwommen bekannt
vorkommt richtig das war alles schon im
april 2020 beschlossen worden an damals
im sogenannten zuge der sogenannten stvo
novelle da ging es dann auch eben um den
schutz von radfahrern und so weiter es
ging aber auch um
wesentlich mehr fahrverbote es sollte
zum beispiel ab 21 km h pro stunde also
eine überschreitung von 21 km h schon
einen monat fahrverbot geben können
außerorts ab 26 km h überschreitung das
ist natürlich ich sag mal schnell
passiert wenn man auf der autobahn
irgendwie nicht schnell genug runter
bremst wenn die baustelle naht oder so
dann ist man mit 26 km h schnell
geblitzt die autofahrerlobby war
irgendwie auf den barrikaden
das war auch so ein bisschen
hoppla hopp alles gegangen in der
letzten legislaturperiode ist ja relativ
viele sehr hoppla hopp entschieden
wurden der verkehrsminister andreas
scheuer musste sich damals den bundesrat
beugen der hatte nämlich gesagt
irgendwie mehr schutz für radler gibt es
nur wenn wir auch in einem aufwasch mehr
strafen für raser verhängen dann hat
sich also an die scheuer gebeugt hat
aber von anfang an schon gesagt
irgendwie mir gefällt das gar nicht und
hat die fahrverbote als
unverhältnismäßig kritisiert was für ein
glücklicher zufall dass sich dann
relativ schnell herausstellte dass es
einen kleinen aber feinen formfehler gab
jetzt sind wir mal wieder kurz bei den
jura es ging um einen verstoß gegen das
zitiergebot
artikel 80 des grundgesetzes verlangen
liebe jura studentinnen und studenten da
draußen das müsst ihr wissen sonst
durchgefallen durch jede prüfung das
rechtsverordnungen die von der
bundesregierung bundesministern oder
einer landesregierung erlassen werden
ihre gesetzliche rechtsgrundlage angeben
müssen also durch diese pflicht das
jeweils höherrangige gericht bei einem
vollzug durch niedere rechtsform zu
zitieren es geht es eigentlich so um
rechtssicherheit und rechtsklarheit also
soll so klar gemacht werden was wenn
dich hier an was läge ich aus von den
höher rang enormen und worauf stütze ich
diese verordnung die ich jetzt hier
erlassen so und das hätte in diesem fall
bedeutet dass die änderung oder eben
ganz neue regel fahrverbote hätte § 26
absatz 1 nummer 3 stvg stvg nennen
müssen es waren aber nur absätze 1
nummer 2 und 2 genannt so das heißt ein
willkommener keine fehler oder das war
glaube ich damals vor allem aus sicht
von uns an die einen sehr selbe
kommender fehler es folgte in der
politik ein riesenstreit ob das jetzt
alles schuld war in dessen ministerium
das ja schief gegangen war oder ob das
nicht im bundesjustizministerium hatte
gesehen werden müssen dann hat das
ministerium von christine lambrecht
damals zurückgeschossen sie hätten
sowieso viel zu kurze frist bekommen ob
das ganze ding überhaupt zu prüfen es
war alles ein riesen tamtam und in der
praxis war es fast noch mehr tamtam wenn
dann war halt relativ schnell klar hier
ist was unwirksam wahrscheinlich sind
alle fahrverbote und works habe dann gab
es ein riesenchaos weil keiner so genau
wusste welche teile dieser novelle sind
denn jetzt eigentlich noch wirksam und
welche nicht und relativ schnell nachdem
die anwälte bundesweit sich schon die
hände reiben die verkehrsrechner und
sagten juhu kampagnen fuhren fahrverbot
kassiert wie er helfen und so das ist
jetzt alles unwirksam haben die länder
relativ schnell exakt leute das geht so
nicht und die regeln bundesweit außer
vollzug gesetzt und das ganze hat sich
dann jetzt anderthalb jahre lang gezogen
es ist jetzt neu beschlossen wurde und
siehe da jetzt haben wir zwar weiterhin
deutlich höhere bußgelder dabei ist es
also geblieben vor allem was du den
schutz von von fahrradfahrern angeht
aber wir haben kein einziges neues
fahrverbot mehr wir haben also nichts
mehr worüber sich die raser lobby der
autofahrer irgendwie aufregend und das
für unverhältnismäßig halten müsste also
es bleibt dabei ihr solltet nicht rum
rasen das lohnt sich ja ohnehin nicht
es wird trotzdem sehr sehr teuer also in
der ortsplatz dabei und 21 bis 25 km/h
drüber kosten schon 115 euro bußgeld und
außerorts bei über 30 km h darüber ist
man bei 200 euro im monat und relativ
schnell ein fahrverbot wenn man nämlich
innerhalb zwei mal eines jahres eine
krasse geschwindigkeitsüberschreitung
ja das tut weh in ist übrigens
interessant in berlin wird so ein
bisschen geschmunzelt darüber dass ja
dieser ist die novelle just in der
ersten zum ersten termin nach der
bundestagswahl dann aufgerufen wurde im
bundesrat ist ein reiner zufall oder
absicht nach zufall also es wird
gemunkelt dass wahrscheinlich die csu
und an die steuer kein gesteigertes
interesse hatten diese sache noch mal in
erinnerung zu rufen kurz vor der wahl
geholfen hat der union nicht wirklich
wie wir ein wahlergebnis gesehen haben
aber es war ein versuch
also in ordnung ist und jetzt immer noch
nicht in kraft sie muss jetzt noch im
bundesgesetzblatt verkündet werden das
soll alles relativ schnell gehen die
entschließung wurde der bundesregierung
jetzt zugeleitet und die entscheidet
jetzt waren sie sich mit der länder
forderung befasst also das macht dann
auch noch die amtierende bundesregierung
wenn sie das jetzt eben schnell umsetzen
will wobei womit man glaube ich jetzt
ausgehen kann hat ja alles lang genug
gedauert so ist es und wer weiß man wenn
der neue bundesregierung haben hier
leben handy war eigentlich so negativ
ein der plan ist ja jedenfalls so man
hört ja von den sondieren dieser tagen
wirklich nicht viel aber hin und wieder
lässt man einer das wort weihnachten
fallen was uns ja alle hoffen lässt ich
wollte ich gerade sagen wenn schon nicht
mehr die kanzlerin die neujahrsansprache
hält sind doch schon alle happy genau
wobei man sehen wie es wie es dann ist
ich glaube ja der ist die heilig
sprechen die kanzlerin fängt ja in
wahrheit schon an und ich glaube sehr
viele menschen und wir hinten sie noch
sehr stark zurück wünschen jetzt immer
so ist soja merkel nadia vermissen
werden aber naja vielleicht wird mir
noch an unsere worte denken so nach
dieser seligen sehr lebensnahen thema
kommen wir jetzt nach europa elena du
hast mir ein sehr gut so thema
mitgebracht im jahr ein unerfreuliches
im ernstes thema das ja auch gleich uns
noch in unserem schwerpunkt gespräch
beschäftigen wird aber vorab gibt es
quasi ein verwandtes einen kleinen
verwandten dazu nämlich erstmal
beschäftigt ist jetzt in algier nein
genau eine verhandlung am montag und
dienstag dieser woche vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof über eine klage
von polen ungarn gegen eine verordnung
der eu beschlossen im vergangenen jahr
und das ist eine verordnung über die
schon viel auch politisch diskutiert
wurde da geht es darum die
daumenschrauben in finanzieller hinsicht
anzulegen also finanz sanktionen zu
verhindern wenn ein mitgliedsstaat sich
nicht an die rechtsstaatlichkeit
prinzipien im eigenen land hält also
fallen natürlich sofort polen und ungarn
1 und just jene länder haben auch
dagegen geklagt weil sie eben nicht
wollen dass ihn der finanz hand
zugedreht wird weil sie etwa wie wir das
in polen gesehen haben sich gegen die
pis regierung die nationalkonservative
regierung dass erst das
verfassungsgericht untertan gemacht hat
und danach auch noch an den ordentlichen
gerichten
disziplinarkammer und anderes
eingerichtet hat was mit der
unabhängigkeit der richter wie man sie
versteht und wie sie übrigens auch in
artikel 2 des eu vertrages also wo es
ihm auch um die die werte der union geht
was auch dem widerspricht in der
verordnung steht unseren rechtsstaat
mechanismus ideen bringen ja also recht
schutzmechanismus ist ja ein weiter
begriff unter den alles mögliche fällt
da gibt es diesen rechtsstaats
mechanismus aus dem jahr 2014 der so
eine art dialogform und sobald er
erstmal voraussetzung dann letzten endes
in dieses sogenannte artikel sieben
verfahren
führt dass das es übrigens schon länger
gibt als 214 das war sozusagen der erste
nucleus und diese artikel sieben
verfahren bedeutet in der letzten
konsequenz eben dass ein mitgliedsstaat
das stimmrecht entzogen werden kann auf
europäischer ebene
das ist eigentlich natürlich von der
idee her ein ein richtiger mechanismus
wenn man nicht mehr mit stimmen kann ist
es wirklich immer ziemlich blöd aber
die praxis hat gezeigt dass es zu diesem
artikel sieben verfahren nie kommt weil
jedes einzelne land ein vetorecht hat so
dass sich polen immer auf ungern
verlassen kann und ungarn in diesem fall
auf polen indes ging man auf die idee
dann gehen wir doch mal ins geld genau
und dann hat man gesagt wenn das alles
nichts hilft und dieses ewige
miteinander sprechen nichts hilft und
briefe schreiben und so weiter dann muss
man an das geld heran zumal eben auch
gerade polen natürlich von europäischem
geld sehr profitiert und das auch einer
der gründe ist warum nach wie vor ein
ganz großer teil der polen eigentlich
ein relativ positives bild von von der
eu und von europa haben also es gibt
diese verordnung da steht in artikel 1
drin
dass regeln sind regeln fest die zum
schutz des haushalts der union im falle
von verstößen gegen die grundsätze der
rechtsstaatlichkeit in den
mitgliedsstaaten erforderlich sind und
zu diesen maßnahmen gehören zu den
maßnahmen die ergriffen werden können
gehören zum beispiel die auszeit die
aussetzung von zahlungen die
zurückhaltung von tranchen und die
kündigung von darlehen und dafür anders
als im artikel 7 verfahren braucht es
hier keine einstimmigkeit sondern es
reicht eine zweidrittelmehrheit denn
formal geht es eben nicht um sanktionen
gegen ein land sondern so heißt es in
der verordnung schutzvorkehrungen für eu
hausmittel für eu haushaltsmittel
entschuldigung gegen rechtsstaatliche
rechtsstaats widrige verwendung ich habe
heute irgendwie einen knoten in der
zunge
vorkehrung für harte tour
haushaltsmittel ging rechtsstaats
niedrige verwendung ist sind aber auch
kompliziert geworden so jedenfalls das
ist so erdacht worden und auch durch das
europäische gesetzgebungsverfahren
durchgekommen und jetzt wenden sich
polen und ungarn dagegen und es wurde
jetzt zwei tage verhandelt und das
argument von polen und ungarn ist
natürlich nicht nur dass sie das einfach
nicht wollen sondern sie sagen halt
dieser mechanismus umgehe in gewisser
weise das artikel sieben verfahren was
auch stimmt ich hab's ja gerade erklärt
der grund ist eben das artikel 75 hat
sich in der praxis als nicht tauglich
erwiesen und jetzt soll ein anderer
mechanismus hier ob das ein rechtliches
argument ist dass sich hören lässt da
habe ich meine zweifel weil man ja
durchaus verschiedene instrumente
nebeneinander haben kann zumal wenn es
eben formal jedenfalls gar nicht um
sanktionen geht sondern eben um
schutzvorkehrungen für eu
haushaltsmittel eben die idee dass man
eine stadt wo die
das rechtsstaatsprinzip nicht gewährt
ist die richter nicht unabhängig sind
nicht sicher sein kann dass das eu geld
auch rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen
gemäss verwendet wird und das ist
natürlich durchaus ein punkt der sich
hören lässt also wir werden sehen wann
es dort ein urteil aus dem vom
gerichtshof gibt man ist jedem fall dem
was man so hört ist hat der ogh wohl
auch tatsächlich relativ kritisch
nachgefragt ob er sich wirklich nur um
diese saubere verwendung von geldern
gehe nur also er hat das jetzt nicht die
die polnischen und ungarischen argumente
da nicht irgendwie direkt vom tisch
gefegt das kann man jetzt glaube ich
nicht sagen sondern es ist ich glaube
anderthalb tage wurde verhandelt und es
wurde tatsächlich recht viel diskutiert
und nachgefragt genau wobei ich mir so
ein bisschen meine zweifel habt weil er
das finde ich ist an diesem argument ich
gerade gesagt hat durchaus was dran dass
man sagt wenn das denn wenn die und wenn
die justiz nicht unabhängig ist wie soll
man dann sicher sein dass das geld den
rechten rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen
gemäss verwendet wird und so kann dann
so etwas wie noch nie also oder selbst
wenn das nicht die eigentliche
zielrichtung ist sondern nur eine
zusätzliche zielrichtung dann weiß ich
auch nicht ob das deswegen persönlich
geht aber wir werden sehen was der ogh
uns da vorliegt und als vorteil bei
nicht vorliegt und entscheidet das
verfahren wird jedenfalls als
beschleunigt das verfahren betrieben und
so dass wir schon wahrscheinlich bald
mit einer entscheidung rechnen könnt was
auch immer bald beim ok heißt wir lange
der generalanwalt will seine
entscheidung anfang dezember verkriechen
also theoretisch wäre es denkbar dass er
vielleicht sogar vielleicht nicht in
diesem jahr anfangen das anfangen die
ersten quartal des kommenden jahres so
habe es auch gehört wir halten sie
natürlich auf dem laufenden
liebe hörerinnen und hörer
[Musik]
so liebe hörerinnen und hörer und das
leitet uns direkt über zum
schwerpunktthema des heutigen tages auch
da geht es um polen genauer gesagt um
ein urteil des polnischen
verfassungsgerichts vom vergangenen
donnerstag
es geht um das verhältnis von polnischer
verfassung und europäischem recht das
urteil hat scharfe kritik hervorgerufen
den europäischen hauptstädten und in
brüssel kommissionspräsidenten von der
leyen hat sich sehr besorgt geäußert
aber matthäus morawski der polnische
ministerpräsident hat nach dem urteil
gesagt naja polen wäre es halt nicht
mehr hinnehmen länger als land zweiter
klasse in der europäischen union
behandelt zu werden also ordentlich
zündstoff ist in diesem urteil darum
darum werden wir uns jetzt kümmern wir
werden die rechtlichen aspekte
beleuchten aber auch die politischen und
dazu begrüße ich jetzt sehr herzlich
reinhard feser bei uns in der sendung
reinhard feser ist osteuropa experte der
faz er ist in frankfurt aber auch sehr
viel in polen unterwegs ist ein kenner
polens und insbesondere des polnischen
justizsystems und ich freue mich sehr
ein hat dass du heute bei uns bist
herzlich willkommen
yaez reinert dann erzähl uns doch
erstmal was das verfassungsgericht da
eigentlich genau entschieden hat das
verfassungsgericht hat entschieden dass
die artikel
194 unions vertrags teilweise nicht mit
der polnischen verfassung vereinbar sein
artikel eins ist immer enge union hat
die
4.3 der
grundsatz filialen zusammenarbeit und
artikel 19 der garantie des rechts zu
jazz in allen angelegenheiten die von eu
recht erfasst werden und
diese punkte hat das verfassungsgericht
in frage gestellt mit der etwas
theologisch klingende die gründung die
seien dann nicht mit der polnischen
verfassung vereinbar wenn die eu
kommission und der algerier durch die
verträge festgelegten kompetenzen
überschritten
und das sind aber in zwei weiteren
punkten
ihres urteils als die geben an dass
ihnen sagen der eth und die
eu-kommission hätten nicht das recht
sich in die gestalt der polnischen
justiz einzumischen und
sie verbieten damit auch polnischen
richtern ausdrücklich
die entscheidungen die aus sicht des
verfassungsgerichtes
oder des polnischen gesetzes nicht
mit deutschem recht vereinbar sind
in polen anzuwenden und sie verbieten
was sozusagen zum ausgangspunkt des
verfahrens führt verbieten des
polnischen richtern auch zu prüfen ob
richter
aufrecht gehen rechtmäßigen wege in ihr
amt gekommen sind also kann man sagen
damit machen sie eigentlich das
unmöglich was die europäische kommission
und der seit einigen jahren tun nämlich
die änderung des polnischen
justizsystems scharf zu kritisieren und
möglicherweise auch zu sanktionieren
ganz genau das war auch der anlass punkt
anders für dieses verfahren
das auf antrag von ministerpräsident
maruf ski zustande kam und zwar als
reaktion auf ein urteil des bgh vom
zweiten märz wo es eben um justizreform
und
damals hat es auf hat der euro auf
antrag des obersten gerichts in polen
festgestellt
dass solche normen im polnischen recht
nicht angewandt werden sollen und dürfen
die im widerspruch zum eu-recht stehen
es ging konkret darum um die frage der
berufung von richtern was eben einen
streitpunkt zwischen eu und polen seit
langen ist ich meine das ist ja schon
sehr erstaunlich war ja der ogh in
dieser entscheidung vom 2 märz 20 21 die
du gerade zitiert hast im grunde eine
selbstverständlichkeit formuliert hat
die wir kennen und die liebe hören und
höre auch sie kennen seite berühmten
entscheidung costa l aus dem jahre 1964
also ganz noch als die eu in dem kinder
oder damals war es gar nicht die eu
sondern die europäischen gemeinschaften
in den kinderschuhen steckten nämlich
der vorgang vorrang des europäischen
rechts vor nationalem recht das hat
jetzt das polnisch verfassungsgericht in
frage gestellt und damit ja kann man
sagen wirklich die axt an einen pfeiler
der europäischen union gesetzt
interessanterweise beruft sich am ohr an
jetzt in dem antrag auf eine
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und zwar auf
die entscheidung die wir hier auch im
podcast besprochen haben vom fünften mai
20 20 die sogenannte ezb-entscheidung
kurz zur erinnerung worum es ging das
bundesverfassungsgericht hatte die
wertpapierkäufe der ezb beanstandet und
eben gesagt dass dieses programm das ist
2015 gibt dass die ezb damit ihr mandat
für die geldpolitik überspannt und hat
nicht nur die ezb kritisiert sondern
auch den ogh der diese praxis gebilligt
hatte und hat dann diese formulierung
gewählt die entscheidung des
europäischen gerichtshofs sei
schlechterdings nicht
nachvollziehbar und schon damals gab es
ja für diese entscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts applaus aus ungarn
und aus polen die gesagt haben seht ihr
wir sind nicht die einzigen die neugier
kritisieren sondern auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht tut es und
jetzt beruft sich wieder moral jetzt auf
das verfassungsgericht sein hat was
sagst du dazu naja das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja
tatsächlich einen sehr konkreten fall
geäußert und dem prinzipiellen vorrang
des europäischen rechts vor nationalem
recht ausdrücklich bekräftigt
was das polnische verfassungsgericht
jetzt gemacht hat geht weit darüber
hinaus zum einen weil eben drei
kernprinzipien
des eu-vertrags angegangen werden eben
die erwähnten artikel 14 und 19 und zum
anderen weil das sehr pauschal getan
wird
also im ersten und wichtigsten teil der
des urteils
müssen sich die polnischen erfassungs
richter vollkommene vom eigentlichen
anlass
des antrags jetzt im rat jetzt gibt's
beim verfassungsgericht gehen gar nicht
mehr auf die frage der justizreform ein
sondern sagen nur
und dass er wie gesagt eine vollkommene
allgemeinen formulierung
diese drei artikeln des eu vertrags
seien nicht mit der polnischen
verfassung vereinbar wenn die
europäische integration eine neue etappe
einleite in der polen kein souveräner
staaten er sei wann das erreicht ist was
die genauen bedingungen sind
unter denen man sagen könnte die eu
nehme polen seine souveränität lag und
so das würde behaupten spezifiziert das
heißt letztlich bekommt durch dieses
urteil des verfassungsgerichts die
polnische regierung ein instrument in
die hand mit dem sie immer unter
berufung auf das ihr fassungs gericht
sagen kann
das hier ist nicht mit der polnischen
verfassung mehr vereinbar und im grund
aussuchen kann welche entscheidungen des
areals überhaupt noch befolgen will
was was übrigens ja auch schon passiert
da ist ja
zwei aktuelle mal ein beispiel dass die
nun den halter justizreformen geht der
ogh hat polen verzichtet die sogenannte
disziplinarkammer am obersten gericht
sofort zu suspendieren und aufzulösen
die ist von der jetzigen regierung neu
geschaffen worden
mit dem ziel richter zu disziplinieren
sie ist ausschließlich besetzt mit
leuten die aus dem nächsten umfeld der
tief kommen sie der regierung ganz nach
konservativen regierungspartei oder gar
zu ihr gehören und damit verbunden ist
nur ein ganzes system von gesetzen zur
disziplinierung von richtern
dass der freiheit sich zu bestimmten
themen zu äußern und zu entscheiden
massiv einschränkt all das ist laut bgh
nicht vereinbar
recht weiß eben die unabhängigkeit der
richter massiv gefährdet und
im juli hat der euro entschieden dass
das dieses ganze system nicht mit
europarecht vereinbar ist und
dieses urteil folgt ohne nicht deswegen
hat die eu kommission bereits beim bgh
einen antrag auf strafzahlungen gestellt
zweites beispiel braucht dann schon gar
nicht mehr um die
frage der justizreform geht ist ein
urteil des bgh zum bäume schmidt
braunkohletagebau tores das ist im
polnisch tschechisch deutschen
dreiländereck ein großer tagebau
tschechien hat dagegen geklagt weil
die umweltauswirkungen auf angrenzende
gemeinden so massiv sind und hat vor dem
eu- recht bekommen
die kohlen folgt diesem urteil nicht da
wird weiter controller abgebaut und
deswegen wurde auch schon jetzt im
september eine strafzahlung von 500.000
euro täglich gegen polen verhängt das
wird aber weiter nicht dazu dass polen
dieses urteil beachtet sondern
ausdrücklich von den
regierungsmitgliedern auch von
ministerpräsident noch wurde angekündigt
kohlen wird dem nicht folgen und
das sieht man eben welche zu welchem
öffnungen die das urteil des
verfassungsgerichts das erst hinterher
gefallen ist führen kann und jetzt sehen
wir noch mal quasi die bestätigung des
verfassungsgerichts schwarz auf weiß
dass das auch völlig in ordnung sei die
urteile des bgh nicht zu respektieren
also wir halten fest es gibt einen
fundamentalen unterschied zwischen der
ezb entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts die jetzt
quasi instrumentalisiert wird von
polnischer seite man sucht jetzt
irgendwie den schulterschluss zu
deutschland aber in diesem fall
tatsächlich vollkommen zu unrecht weil
das verfassungsgericht
eben alles andere als den vorrang des
europäischen rechts in frage gestellt
hat sondern im gegenteil bestätigt hat
und eben nur gesagt hat in diesem einen
punkt hat die ezb die kompetenzen
überschritten das ist diese prüfung die
das bundesverfassungsgericht schon seit
längerer zeit an stellt in der tat aber
gibt es eine diskussion und ich finde
auch zu recht über die frage ob diese
formulierung schlechterdings nicht
nachvollziehbar mit blick auf eine
entscheidung so wahnsinnig glücklich ist
weil es auf den jedenfalls leyen doch
sehr verwunderlich wirkt und nicht
gerade respektvoll dem europäischen
gericht gegenüber aber das ist eine
diskussion die in deutschland geführt
wird und die hat nichts zu tun glaube
ich mit der frage des polnischen urteils
kommen wir noch mal darauf zurück rhein
hat auch aus polen gibt es ja andere
stimmen also stimmen die sagen so geht
es auf keinen fall und das ist nicht nur
donald tusk der ehemalige
ministerpräsident und präsident des
europäischen rats sondern auch richter
die sich geäußert haben oder genau als
es wurde am montag veröffentlichten
offenen brief von
26 jeweiligen richtern des
branchenwachstums gerichts die einfach
eine
liste von punkten auf zellen in denen
das
polnische das jetzige verfassungsgericht
aus ihrer sicht im urteil und dessen
begründung die unwahrheit sagt unter
anderem eben auch in bezug auf die
behauptung sowohl der richter als auch
führende polnische politiker
das polnische verfassungsgericht hat
eigentlich etwas entschieden was im
rahmen dessen ist was andere
verfassungsgerichte in europa ebenfalls
entschieden haben das bezeichnet die
richter ausdrücklich als die wahrheit
und
letztlich kann man sagen dass eigentlich
alles was das soweit ich das überblicken
kann
der polnischen justiz in den vergangenen
30 jahre lang und namen hat
gegen diese entscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts steht so wie es auch
schon eine überwältigende mehrheit der
juristen gab die
eigentlich in jedem einzelnen schritt
der justizreform der us regierung in den
letzten sechs jahren
protestiert haben
wie ist denn eigentlich jetzt der
zustand des polnischen
verfassungsgerichts wenn du sagst
alles was rang und namen hat kritisiert
diese entscheidung was sitzen denn jetzt
für richter am verfassungsgericht und
wie konnte es überhaupt so schnell so
weit kommen ich glaube da kommen der
kern des ganzen denn eigentlich geht es
gar nicht so sehr um juristische fragen
um eine politische frage
das pons verfassungsgericht war das
erste gericht oder die erste institution
der polnischen justiz die
von der pis nach ihrem wahlsieg im
herbst 2015 attackiert wurde damals
haben
parlament regierung und präsident angie
du da in einer konzertierten aktion über
weihnachten die
fast schon staatsstreich artiges gehört
zum teil und gibt die rechtlich
zumindest entziehen punkten sehr
zweifelhaft war
mehrheit aigner zum patienten am
verfassungsgericht herbeigeführt
unter anderem dadurch dass drei plätze
am verfassungsgericht die eigentlich
besetzt waren und uns vom vorherigen
parlament ersetzt worden waren einfach
noch mal besetzt wurden
diese drei werke jetzt von kritikern
immer als doppelgänger bezeichnet und
alle drei waren auch an der entscheidung
vom vergangenen donnerstag beteiligt man
muss sagen das verfassungsgericht in
seiner jetzigen form ist
ein politisches instrument der tiefs
geworden die vorsitzende julia zu
samstag
ist vom tiefsten
jaroslaw kaczynski der letztlich der
entscheidende mann allen in politischen
fragen ist
als die freundschafts entdeckung der
vergangenen jahre bezeichnet worden und
er sei auch bei ihr zu gast hat er in
einem interview
mal gesagt
zwei der richter die
ende 2009 10 an land wurden die waren
vorher für die tief im parlament einer
der beiden ein stanislawski trobitz war
in der ersten phase dieses so genannten
justizreformen der frust des
justizausschusses des polnischen
parlament das heißt er hat die ganzen
veränderungen im bayerischen justiz
nächsten über die das verfassungsgericht
und der eth jetzt im kind liegen
eigentlich maßgeblich
mit vorangetrieben als politiker und
kleine fußnote die pis begründet ihre
justizreformen ja auch damit dass es
darum gehe lässt überbleibsel der
kommunistischen diktatur aus dem aus der
polnischen justiz zu entfernen djokovic
war in kommunistischer zeit staatsanwalt
und er war während des kriegsrechts
anfang der 80er jahre an der verfolgung
ist wenigstens eines oppositionellen
beteiligt und hat dass wir auch einen
orden bekommen so dass das ganze zeigt
das ist natürlich etwas anekdotisch aber
das ganze zeigt
eben was das jetzt sind gericht ist
dieses polnische fassungs gericht das
erklärt auch dass täglich zeigen die
entscheidung mehrfach verschoben wurde
dann ganz offensichtlich ging es
zunächst einmal darum abzuwarten ob die
eu kommission die mittel aus dem corona
wiederaufbau vor polen freigibt oder
nicht es wird darüber spekuliert warum
zu der entscheidung kam obwohl die
mittel nicht freigegeben wurden aber
vielleicht hatte die regierung einfach
die hoffnung verloren ja interessant
also wir sehen ein politisch komplett
politisch agieren das gericht man kann
sagen vielleicht ein von vornherein
abgekartetes spiel also [ __ ] ab jetzt
hat den antrag gestellt weil er wusste
welches ergebnis rauskommt und man hat
noch versucht so lange zu warten bis die
eu gelder frei gibt
es gab mir glaube ich eine vorsichtige
andeutung dass es so kommen könne und
dann kam doch das urteil also
interessante analyse dass sie vielleicht
die hoffnung aufgegeben haben und sich
jetzt einfach
ja die volle konfrontation zur eu suchen
es gab ja auch stimmen aus bund jetzt
gesagt haben wir brauchen dieses
europäische geld gar nicht so dringend
das ist wohl ein vorgeschobenes argument
denn in wahrheit ist es ja meines
erachtens jedenfalls so dass polen auf
die hilfen
sehr wohl angewiesen ist aber einer wie
bewertest du denn jetzt dieses urteil
politisch und im
blick auf das grundsätzliche verhältnis
der eu zu polen jetzt ist ja schon das
wort vom poleksic macht die runde ist
das ein wirklich szenario ein
realistisches szenario das wir jetzt
befürchten müssen das ist die große
offene frage
es ist im moment noch nicht ganz klar
wie die was die regierung jetzt mit
diesem urteil genau zu machen gedenkt
aber nach der erfahrung
die man mit ihr in den vergangenen
jahren machen musste wird sie das
wahrscheinlich einfach nach politischer
opportunität
nutzen und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass die eu jetzt noch
zu großen zugeständnissen konzessionen
gegenüber polen bereit ist da
gab es auch schon entsprechende stimmen
aus brüssel das eigentlich jetzt die
auszahlung der gelder
aus dem corona wiederaufbau von erstmal
überhaupt nicht vorstellbar ist und es
läuft ja gerade dass klage vor dem eugh
th die von ungarn und polen
eingeschränkt wurde genau darüber haben
wir schon gesprochen
gerade bevor du zugeschaltet wurde das
okay dann muss dazu nicht sagen
also die frage ist zeigen droht jetzt
der paul exit
die regierung sagt das ist ein ästhet
geräte über den par lag sie zwar ein
fake der opposition als willig truhe der
nicht
polen sei fest in der eu es wolle nur
eine eu haben die die nationale
souveränität
polens achte in der polen kein mitglied
zweiter klasse sein
tatsache ist aber sonder dass die gefahr
sehr real ist und zwar auf zwei ebenen
zum einen mal
könnte es ihnen passieren dass polen
jetzt wie aus dem europäischen
rechtsraum hinaus geleitet denn wenn
entscheidungen des bgh in polen nicht
mehr angewandt werden dann heißt es
letztlich dass das europarecht dort zum
teil nicht mehr angewandt wird und da
könnte so ein schleichender prozess in
gang kommen mit allen möglichen
nebenwirkungen auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaft auf die rechtssicherheit von
unternehmen und investoren und so weiter
der nächste punkt ist wenn das geld
jetzt nicht ausgezahlt wird und polen de
facto aus den ganzen umverteilung des
mechanismen eu ausgeschlossen wird
wird auch das jetzt so dass ein de facto
hinaus gleiten und der nächste punkt ist
der womöglich
tatsächlich auch eine rolle spielen wird
ist das einfach durch diese ganze
situation auch eine politische dynamik
in gang gesetzt werden kann die auch
irgendwann zu einem austritt entschluss
führt die dies schraubt ihre rhetorik
gegenüber der eu immer weiter hoch es
kommt zu vollkommen aberwitzigen
vergleichen führender politiker der
teams hat neulich die eu mit der
deutschen besatzung während des zweiten
weltkriegs und mit der sowjetischen
besatzung die folgte verglichen
der justizminister spricht von einem
briten angriff der eu auf polen und man
muss sagen in polen ist zwar eine ganz
klare mehrheit der bevölkerung also in
umfragen über jahre konstant
80 6%
glas für die eu wirtschaft polens aber
erstens weiß man nicht wie es sagen
diese massive
massiven attacken die polen vor allem in
kleineren städten und ländlichen
gegenden wo das staatliche fernsehen
geschaut wird tagtäglich aus dem
fernsehen bekommen ob die nicht sagen
diese einstellungen verändern und
nächster punkt der anteil der offenen
die gegner in der partei selbst und in
der parlamentsfraktion ist deutlich
kühler als
in der gesamtbevölkerung
und es ist durchaus denkbar dass das die
sich einfach in eine sackgasse reinreden
dass sie
ohne gesichtsverlust gar nicht mehr
rauskommen und
und keinen schritt mehr gehen können und
eine austritt polenz aus der eu ist
anders als den eintritt kein referendum
nötig dazu reichten parlaments
entschlossen aber es ist ja wenn man
gegen jetzt zuhört klingt es ja wirklich
so als ob es so kommen könnte aber
schneidet sich damit nicht polen
komplett ins eigene fleisch also was zum
beispiel jetzt die finanziellen mittel
angeht was ja ich glaube ich einer der
gründe ist warum 80 prozent der polen ja
eigentlich ein positives bild von der eu
haben weil eben doch so für europäisches
geld in das land fließt vielleicht noch
kurz zum ende was würde das für die lage
in polen bedeuten und vielleicht auch
noch ein paar sätze was würde das
eigentlich was wäre eigentlich eine eu
ohne polen weil polen bedeuten würde
in der tat es ist eine liberal
konservative zeitung gab es gestern eine
reaktions kommentar
also wir haben der gesamten redaktion in
der es heißt der text war ein tödlicher
stoß für polen ist so ein bisschen die
befürchtung bei vielen das einfach jetzt
etwas in gang kommt was vergleichbar ist
mit dem was vor dem brett sit in
großbritannien war
david cameron wollte ja auch nicht
offenbar aus der eu aus aber er hat
dieses referendum angesetzt aus
innenpolitischen gründen und so herrscht
in polen die früchte mann konnte aus
innenpolitischen gründen
versehentlich aus der eu aus und leiten
und das wäre wirtschaftlich eine
katastrophe nicht nur wegen der direkten
finanzmittel die die die polen von der
eu erhält sondern auch wegen der
unglaublich engen verflechtung der
polnischen wirtschaft mit den übrigen eu
raum ist der rest sicherheitspolitischen
katastrophe daher wird auch jetzt in
polen viel gesprochen denn natürlich ist
die eu-mitgliedschaft zu polen nicht nur
eine wirtschaftliche angelegenheit
sondern auch eine ganz massive
sicherheitspolitische komponente
in bezug auf das immer aggressiver
auftreten der russland in bezug auf die
probleme die man gerade an der grenze zu
bilder aussieht
und das ist natürlich auch die frage was
heißt das für die eu es zum einen mal
auch soll auch für deutschland wäre das
eine katastrophe denn auch für die
deutsche wirtschaft ist die polnische
wirtschaft mittlerweile sehr sehr
wichtig das wird in deutschland
vielleicht nicht immer ganz so
wahrgenommen aber tatsächlich ist es so
und auch dann hat man den den
sicherheitspolitischen aspekte ganze
display division in unserer
unmittelbaren östlichen nachbarschaft
das wäre auch für deutschland und dem
rest der eu sehr sehr unerfreulich also
jedenfalls würde die eu einen ausstieg
polens wohl noch viel schlechter
verkraften als den ausstieg der ausstieg
der briten die an manchen punkt nie so
richtig dabei waren so jedenfalls ist
die analyse die man aus brüssel hört
reinhard dann enden wir einfach mit der
hoffnung dass es vielleicht doch nicht
so kommen wird dass sich die polen doch
eines besseren
besinnen mögen immerhin ist es ja so
dass die ps2 jetzt seit einigen jahren
die mehrheit hat aber doch auch keine
sehr sehr große das heißt es gibt auch
viele oppositionelle im land die auf die
eu hoffen und die darauf hoffen dass
sich dieses land nicht weiter in dieser
autoritäre richtung bewegt dann hoffen
wir also mit ihnen und reinheit ich
danke dir sehr für die keine erhellenden
wenn auch deprimierenden worte zur lage
in polen und zu dem urteil dank dir und
einen schönen tag noch danke gleichfalls
zu fühlen
so und
wir wieder zurück und zwar mit einem
thema das nur auf den ersten blick
profan nach wirtschaft klingt ich bin
vor einigen tagen über eine studie
gestolpert zum thema whistleblowing und
zwar ist das eine studie der schweizer
fachhochschule graubünden die gemeinsam
mit einer unternehmensberatung erstellt
wurde und die zeigt dass also darüber
hatte ich glaube die taz berichtet und
diese studie zeigt tatsächlich sehr
deutlich dass deutsche unternehmen
extrem schlecht vorbereitet sind auf die
sogenannte whistleblowing richtlinie so
diese büttelborn richtlinie ist im
dezember 2009 10 in kraft getreten und
müsste in deutschland bis zum 17
dezember umgesetzt werden
und ist ein klar das ist bislang nicht
geschehen und das wird wohl auch nicht
mehr geschehen wir haben es vorhin schon
gehört also wenn wir weihnachten neue
regierung haben werde es gut gelaufen da
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts mehr
kommen vielleicht liegt es daran dass
nach dieser studie bislang nur jedes
siebte unternehmen in deutschland die
anforderungen dieser richtlinie erfüllt
ich war davon so ein bisschen überrascht
weil ich halt aus relativ vielen
wirtschaftskanzleien höre dass die
unternehmen sich sehr wohl damit
beschäftigten gerade im zuge von
compliance ist das thema whistleblowing
eigentlich relativ weit oben auf der
agenda gelandet aber natürlich
vielleicht liegt das auch daran dass man
als anwaltskanzlei natürlich irgendwie
diesen eindruck hat weil die unternehmen
sicher dann damit irgendwie an kanzleien
wänden ist natürlich nicht repräsentativ
und jetzt zeigt sich ob es relativ viele
unternehmen haben da wohl noch nicht so
richtig viel gemacht
die whistleblowing richtlinie ist
eigentlich dazu da um whistleblower
besser zu schützen also es geht darum
dass die die politik auf eu-ebene gesagt
hat dass man rechtlich relevante
vorgänge in unternehmen oder eben
anderen closed shops besser aufdecken
muss und besser bedeutet eben vor allem
geschützter damit whistleblower keine
nachteile zu befürchten haben es ist ja
irgendwie klar dass erstmal ne zwischen
schmutz nicht sehr schätzen und auf der
anderen seite ist natürlich auch klar
dass solche nestbeschmutzer in
anführungszeichen also hinweisgeber
total wichtig sein können um halt
missstände aufzudecken das heißt diese
richtlinie verpflichtet unternehmen ab
250 mitarbeitenden eben jetzt schon ab
dezember 20 21 und ab 50 mitarbeitenden
ab 20 23 zu einrichtungen anna
meldestellen so soll garantiert werden
dass sich hinweisgeber idealerweise
anonym melden können mindestens aber
vertraulich bei den unternehmen melden
können und wichtig repressalien für
hinweis geben dafür ist deshalb nicht
geben also wer missstände im eigenen
unternehmen aufdecken kann nicht deshalb
mit fadenscheinigen begründungen
gekündigt werden oder sonstigen
negativen konsequenzen ausgesetzt werden
so
jetzt ist es eine richtlinie wir wissen
also das ding erwächst nicht unmittelbar
in nationales recht sondern muss
eigentlich umgesetzt werden das hat die
bundesregierung in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode nicht auf die reihe
gekriegt es gab zwar ein entwurf das
hinweisgeber schutzgesetz aus dem
bundesjustizministerium
das ist aber blockiert wurden von der
union und zwar mit der begründung damals
dass das bmj v nicht whistleblower nicht
nur dann schützen wollte wenn sie
verstöße gegen eu recht auf decken also
das sozusagen umsetzen was in der
richtlinie steht sondern auch dann wenn
sie verstöße gegen nationales recht
aufdecken und da hat die union gesagt i
die unternehmen sind doch sowieso so
belastet gerade so in der korona krise
und jetzt können wir keine
überschießende umsetzung machen also ich
bin mir persönlich nicht so ganz im
klaren darüber ob das wirklich eine
überschießende umsetzung wäre wenn man
tatsächlich von hinweisgebern erstmal
irgendwie erwarten würde dass sie keine
ahnung zum anwalt gehen um abzuklären ob
der missstand den sie gerne auf decken
möchten denn gegen europäisches oder
auch gegen deutsches recht verstößt und
wenn ja welchen weg sie daneben sollen
also das klingt für mich ehrlich gesagt
schon ziemlich hanebüchen aber wie auch
immer long story short es gab keine
umsetzung so und jetzt habe ich mich
dann bei gefragt was passiert denn jetzt
am siebzehnten zwölften können die
unternehmen sich einfach entspannt
zurücklegen und keine linden und keiner
muss bisher irgendwas tun weil ja
sowieso die rechtlich umgesetzt wurde
das einzige was uns müssen ich weiß es
nicht und das weiß offenbar auch niemand
so genau also das einzige was klar ist
dass die eu dann ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
deutschland einleiten könnte das steht
fest und dann strafzahlung genau ja also
das ist jetzt glaube ich das einzige was
irgendwie relativ klar und eindeutig ist
die wichtige frage aber was denn jetzt
mit den unternehmen ist die dass im
moment ja offensichtlich noch ein
bisschen verschlafen oder vor sich
herschieben die konnte mir niemand
beantworten bisher mit niemand meine ich
habe ein zwei professoren aus dem
öffentlichen recht gefragt die haben
alle schon gesagt das kommt auf
richtlinien und dann habe ich auch noch
mal im bmj angerufen und tatsächlich hat
das auch das bmj frau gesagt das kommt
auf die richtlinie jahren man könne ja
irgendwie nach der rechtsprechung des
ogh nicht so richtig sagen also vorab
prognostizieren ob man von der
unmittelbaren wirkung der richtlinie
ausgehen kann wohl zu lasten privater
unternehmen er nicht also es ist
tatsächlich so also jetzt wirklich nur
ganz grob ausgedrückt und ich weiß nicht
welcher fall jetzt hier greift
richtlinie die nicht umgesetzt wird
nicht pünktlich in den mitgliedstaat ist
könnte theoretisch wenn sie hinreichend
konkret formuliert ist trotzdem jemanden
schon binden aber wohl allenfalls
behörden und mich private unternehmen so
weit so gut das wären also erst mal good
news für die unternehmen andererseits
wäre es aber auf jeden fall denkbar dass
sich zum beispiel ein arbeitnehmer deren
deren hinweis gibt und dann danach
gekündigt wird als beispiel im wegen
dieses hinweises der könnte sich dann
zum beispiel darauf berufen dass das
unternehmen die anforderungen der
richtlinie nicht erfüllt hat und könnte
sich also gegen sie gegenüber seinem
arbeitgeber auf die richtlinie berufen
und sogar theoretisch schadensersatz
gegenüber der bundesrepublik geltend
machen weil die richtlinie nicht
umgesetzt hat in nationales recht das
ist natürlich alles ehrlich gesagt super
theoretisch und wird jetzt bestimmt
nicht am 19 dezember passieren das ist
alles sehr sehr formal juristisch
irgendwie aber ich meine helene wie
siehst du das ich gehe davon aus dass
diese umsetzung vor allem menschen die
ampel gibt sehr sehr schnell kommen
würde das habe ich das habe ich auch den
anderen nicht an der spd sondern wie du
gesagt dass dann der union insofern kann
ich mir das auch sehr gut vorstellen es
ist auch in der sage ich mal politischen
großwetterlage schon ein konsequenter
schritt wenn
wir sagen na ja es gibt diese es gibt
diese missstände in unternehmen es gibt
diese skandale in unternehmen
korruption und da weiß ja jeder dass der
staatsanwalt schon außen da relativ
wenig sehen und tun kann sondern da
braucht man halt die hinweisgeber die ja
auch in der vergangenheit schon ja dazu
beigetragen habe neben ja da muss man
jetzt wenn man die auf mich ja gar nicht
aus noten zurückschauen sondern auf die
dame die vor an absoluten über facebook
ausgepackt hat das war ja eine ehemalige
die jetzt ich würde mal sagen zumindest
in dieser eindeutigkeit erstmalig so
einblicke in dieses system facebook gibt
was ja ein extrem closed shop die man
natürlich nur durch mitarbeitende oder
ex mitarbeitende kriegen kann
absolut und insofern ist es natürlich
die machen das aber nur dann wenn sie in
ein ja in schutz auch dafür bekommen und
deswegen wie ist es eigentlich
konsequent und so würde ich sagen
jedenfalls mit einer ampel wird das dann
schnell gehen auch das werden wir sehen
da kommt auch hier erst mal darauf an
wie schnell es denn mit der ampel und
das ist glaube ich auch nicht nur auf
politischer ebene ein thema für dass es
durchaus eine eine gewisse awareness
gibt sondern eben auch in der wirtschaft
habe ich den eindruck dass es da eine
sehr sehr hohe awareness eigentlich für
gibt so dass es mich eigentlich
gewundert hat dass so viele unternehmen
bisher noch nicht umgesetzt haben zumal
natürlich ist es klar dass man als
unternehmen auf den allerersten blick
wahrscheinlich keine lust darauf hat das
müssten blauer irgendwie sich meldet und
sagt hier läuft einiges schief auf der
anderen seite muss man sich glaube ich
schon bewusst machen dass man daran
dringend ein interesse haben sollte weil
ja auch den unternehmen massive schäden
dadurch entstehen dass solche dass das
solche missstände nicht aufgedeckt
werden und es ist natürlich vor allem
besseren linken ohr sich intern melden
und den unternehmen ja damit fairerweise
die gelegenheit geben das selbe zu
beseitigen als wenn sie sich weil sie
angst haben vor repressionen im eine
repressalien im eigenen unternehmen an
die presse oder die öffentlichkeit
wenden absolut so ist es deswegen finde
ich das auch immer zu einfach und platt
gedacht zu sagen das sei jetzt
denunziantentum dass damit gefördert
werden solle sondern es geht schlicht
darum missstände aufzudecken und wie du
sagst erstmal intern um die fehler
sofort zu beseitigen von denen ja
teilweise die führungsebenen auch gar
nichts wissen oder möglicherweise auch
nichts wissen wollen aber sie müssen
eben damit konfrontiert werden also und
der mann da an insgesamt fairen
wettbewerb denkt muss man jetzt sagen
das funktioniert eben auch nur dann wenn
sich alle an die regeln halten und da
sind auch die mitarbeiter wichtig dazu
aufzurufen also da sind wir uns einer
meinung dann können wir dann auch
weitergehen du hast noch ein nachtrag
zur genauso haben von einem wie corinna
sagen wurde hinreisen den hörer noch
ganz tolle quasi film und fernseh tipps
bekommen nach unserer letzten folge in
der wir relativ ausführlich über das
thema vormundschaft von britney spears
gesprochen haben und dann in der folge
über den usa jetzt geplanten free
britney act haben wir tipps bekommen und
zwar zum thema missbrauch von form und
schafften in den usa also es ging ja
eben in dem fall von britney spears
darum so zu sagen dass möglicherweise
der vater seine vormundschaft über sie
missbraucht hat und tatsächlich scheint
das in den scheint es in den usa da ein
massives problem zu geben mit dem
missbrauch in formen schafften vor allem
von senioren und da hat uns ein
hinreißender höre ich zitiere kommen hat
er sehr gern noch mal irgendwie mehrere
tipps geschickt die wir euch auch in die
chance packen und zwar gibt es dazu eine
sehr interessante folge der last week
tonight show mit jon oliver es gibt
einen forbes artikel der einen ähnlichen
fall auch finde ich sehr eindringlich
schildert und wer es dann doch lieber
auf der unterhaltungsabend es gibt den
netflix film carol oates ich habe ihn
immer noch nicht gesehen obwohl ich ihn
seit monaten auf meiner watchlist hab
mit der hinreißenden rosamund pike dem
ex bond girl also ich glaube es lohnt
sich auch optisch das anzuschauen wir
möchten aber es wegen des themas
empfehlen und bedanken uns sehr für
diese wunderbaren film und fernseh tipps
auch das geben wir doch in unserem
rechts podcast gern mal weiter oder
helene
vielen dank für die tipps und eine
aufforderung damit oder eine bitte
natürlich sich gerne mit kritik oder
applaus oder was auch immer anmerkungen
berichtigungen zu wort zu melden auf den
bekannten kanälen da bleibt uns dann
noch das gerechte urteil das gerechte
urteil soll noch ein bisschen wild muss
ich sagen also das ovg in nordrhein
westfalen hat entschieden dass ein
mieter verein aus regensburg eine
qualifizierte einrichtung im sinne von
vier unterlassungsklagen gesetz ist
klingt formalistisch ist es aber nicht
also
das ovg nrw hat entschieden dass dieser
verein bestimmte verbandsklagen führen
darf dh der mieterverein darf quasi
jetzt in zukunft klagen führen für
verbraucher also außergerichtlich und
gerichtlich vorgehen gegen verbraucher
schädigende oder wettbewerbswidrige und
unlautere praktiken das ist eben eine
ausnahme dass bestimmte vereine und
verbände ich glaube seit anfang der 2000
ist das glaube ich ungefähr der fall für
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
vorgehen dürfen in zu kleineren fällen
zum beispiel eben wenn es um unwirksame
allgemeine geschäftsbedingungen geht und
so der klassiker sind ja eigentlich
verbraucherzentrale das kennt man also
die gehen dann ständig durch alle
instanzen zb das letzte urteil ist
glaube ich erst eine woche oder
anderthalb her und wehren sich gegen zum
beispiel banken agb die dann unwirksam
sind und dann hat man eben quasi ein
grundsatzurteil für alle so und es gibt
jetzt zur quasi begrenzung der ja wie
soll man sagen begrenzung der
einrichtungen die solche klagen für
verbraucher führen dürfen gibt es eine
liste die wird geführt beim bundesamt
für justiz das ist eine abschließende
liste und man kann halt einst als verein
oder verband beantragen auf diesel ist
auf dieser liste geführt zu werden so
wer darf da geführt werden das sind
müssen eben irgendwie bestimmte vereine
oder verbände sein die bestimmte
voraussetzungen erfüllen müssen also die
müssen sich zur satzungsmäßigen aufgabe
gemacht haben interessen von
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
wahrzunehmen und zwar durch aufklärung
und beratung die auch nicht gewerbsmäßig
sein darf es gibt auch noch ein paar
andere voraussetzungen also dass dürfen
zum beispiel keine völlig unbedeutenden
mini verbände seien die halt nur fünf
mitglieder haben die muss es schon eine
gewisse zeit geben und wir erinnern uns
an die diskussionen um die deutsche
umwelthilfe die dürfen ihre ansprüche
nicht vorwiegend deshalb geltend machen
weil sie sich selbst damit finanzieren
möchten also zum beispiel durch
abmahnungen oder vertragsstrafen oder
sonne da gab es ja immer so leidige
diskussion und die deutsche umwelthilfe
selbstverständlich steht irgendwie die
deutsche umwelthilfe auf dieser liste
drauf ich habe da mal reingeschaut da
steht auch der adac darauf zum beispiel
der bund der versicherten aber auch
foodwatch und wie ich dann festgestellt
habe zahlreiche mietervereine das ist ja
schon relativ verstärkt auch gedacht das
wäre der prototyp deshalb bin ich auch
so über dieses urteil gestolperten
dachte mir naja das ist ja eigentlich
total selbstverständlich wer soll denn
bitte in so einer liste stehen die
verbraucherrechte geltend macht wenn
nicht mietervereine das ist doch der der
der standort eines
verbraucherschutzvereins sozusagen aber
das ovg hat sogar sein eigenes urteil
als grundsatzentscheidung bezeichnet
weil sie sich gewehrt haben gegen eine
ständige verwaltungspraxis des
bundesamts für justiz und zwar sagt das
bundesamt für justiz
seit jahren mietervereine dürfen da
eigentlich nicht mitmachen und zwar weil
sie nur die eigenen mitglieder
individuell beraten und eben nicht alle
verbraucher wie es quasi das klappt
möchte so und jetzt hat wie schon das
verwaltungsgericht köln das ovg hier in
nordrhein westfalen gesagt das stimmt
zwar irgendwie dass diese vereine sich
in ihrem tätigkeitsbereich an die
verbraucher schafft insgesamt wenden
müssen heisst aber nicht dass wenn
jemand nur die eigenen mitglieder berät
man auf keinen fall da irgendwie
aufgenommen werden darf sondern es geht
eben darum sagt das ovg nrw das ist eine
dass die diese leistungen dieses vereins
für eine größere anzahl von verbrauchern
im tätigkeitsbereich des vereins merkbar
sein muss und dieser mieterverein
regensburg hat er halt nachgewiesen dass
er regelmäßig jährlich ungefähr 5000
oder mehr individuelle persönliche und
telefonische einzelberatung seiner
mitglieder macht und zudem irgendwie
umfangreich insgesamt dreht also und da
hat das ovg sehr sehr deutlich gesagt
bei fast 5000 metern als mitgliedern die
diese beratungstätigkeit in erheblichem
umfang in anspruch nehmen steht die
wirksamkeit der verbraucherberatung
außer frage punkt
würde ich auch so sehen zumal ja auch
auf den internetseiten dieser
mietervereine durchaus auch informiert
wird habe ich mich auch schon informiert
habe auch rechtsrat tatsächlich schon
gefunden also und man kann ja auch ganz
unproblematisch beitreten ja also ich
meine dass wir es schon eine sehr enge
auslegung
dieser dieser ich habe dann auch noch
über nachgefragt beim ovg und hab gesagt
leute wieso braucht es denn jetzt eine
grundsatzentscheidung wenn doch schon
relativ viele mieterverein in dieser
liste drin stehen und tatsächlich wusste
der sina pass auch nicht
beim ovg haben die gemutmaßt es könnte
noch war sozusagen von vor dieser
restriktiven ständigen praxis des
bundesamts der justiz sein oder
vielleicht hatten sie auch vermutet dass
die mietervereine die dann aufgenommen
werden wollten die beratung auch nicht
mitgliedern angeboten haben um quasi
aufgenommen zu werden aber es ist auf
jeden fall klar dass das ovg hier
flecker einschlagen wollte gegen diese
ständigen verwaltungspraxis und diese
ständigen verwaltungspraxis die
mietervereine er nicht aufzunehmen hat
das bundesamt für justiz auch ganz
explizit noch einmal bestätigt in dem
verfahren und deshalb haben sie jetzt
auch die revision zum
bundesverwaltungsgericht zu gelassen
wegen grundsätzlicher bedeutung stand
heute war allerdings noch keine revision
eingelegt
na na das ist ja interessant ich meine
wie auch immer man zu dieser
verbandsklage steht ist es ja jedenfalls
schöne rechtsklarheit zu haben oder und
sich nicht in jedem fall immer fragen zu
müssen es zu setzen verband oder ist es
keiner gerade in einem fall von
mietervereinen die ja ich meine vier
millionen mieter gibt sich aber das ist
ja ich war leider auch nicht aber sind
viele viele millionen und auch viele
viele davon die ärger mit ihren
vermietern haben ich jedenfalls hatte
das schon zweimal und einmal musste ich
auch tatsächlich schon klagen und war
erfolgreich mit der rückforderung meiner
kommt so freundlich heute noch sehr
schön dass die hände nicht auch wirklich
das war ein
einwand auch wird es gerade auch also
das ist nicht nur ein gerechtes urteil
sondern jedes andere urteil wäre für
mich richtig geht und gericht gewesen
deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt wie das
jetzt weitergeht in den instanzen
wir werden es auch verfolgen und weiter
darüber berichten pia es war wie immer
eine freude meine ja noch sagen was ich
ja immer noch sagen muss dass liebe
hörerinnen und hörer sie sich natürlich
auch weiter informieren können wenn
gerade kein podcast läuft nicht nur auf
der normalen zeitung faz und auf der
website wo wir natürlich auch viele
juristische themen jeden tag haben zum
beispiel jetzt die parteienfinanzierung
die auch vom bundesverfassungsgericht
verhandelt wurde und anderes sondern
auch natürlich insbesondere unter faz
einspruch punkt.de wo sie auch ein abo
klicken können das noch mal nur in
erinnerung gerufen und jetzt bleibt mir
der eine schöne woche zu wünschen
nächste woche ist wieder corinna hier
und ich freue mich darauf dass ich im
november auch wieder dabei bin machen
sie es gut
vielen dank für eine wundervolle tochter
[Musik]